my name feel bad welcome back to mr.
chair staring at some fun shared
community
I'm coming penny but I I don't like this
well I saw you
Hey are you scared you know cut it's
someone coughing and you know showing
your ads conceal oh this is awkward this
is really uh oh it's coming up stay down
oh you're angry like no how do you ask
me from that oh you ate your friend ha
ha whoa double hit your friend how you
doing sir nice fake boot diet if you
don't like it then you should who take a
crowbar e heck Barry are you done I'm
gonna help you open some [ __ ] thank you
thank you oh yeah whoa
I really open that Oh some my scooter oh
my god bring it [ __ ]
you think I'm scared you think I'm scare
huh are they come on where I say whoa I
saw you
Hey
all right if you're wondering what I'm
doing I need a fire axe here cuz it's
impossible okay I'm like the game does
not have know how to work inside to kill
people which I'm really sorry about I'm
trying to save lives here by the way I'm
I'm the cop
oh I saw something hey man you can take
the front door if you want or just jump
it
see the way is fine with me you know I'm
good
so that's messy that's his new name
that's my name smashing that right you
can do pick a pineapple I like that's
making that's why I'm like favorite
attribute of us but we're gonna use
tumbly right now because it's messy that
of a me see come on
thank me this all you have
anyone pitiable but just to make sure
he's dead
come on drop the fight it seems to be
random I don't know I guess is the only
way okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah no problem
why did I read it yeah look at that face
yeah yeah that's what you get for rang
like I got it well I didn't George your
[ __ ] shotgun oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
put your nothing luggage Oh daddy is
this stupid Whitney and eBooks eyes and
bottom right are they reluctant yes and
oh can i buy that
thank ya no more ball for you I'm sorry
about your ball you're like their knife
they like each other
all right everyone dad yeah
all right here what hairs brown all
right all right move piano
step aside piano whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
shadow Kenna Kenna you don't have to
kill yourself
I like sheep gotta come calm down all
right
look out ow
what is this huh no one some one ticket
okay where am I going
perhaps in the hill ha what what are you
doing
don't do it breath down down
oh that's what my mom oh is that you
know berry don't come here to my back I
don't like why did mama
don't sit hug Spears that's what she
said
never hug Spears usually doesn't end
well alright we need to find evidence I
can see something here
Oh someone's been finger-painting who
has a finger-painting I love
finger-painting all right Wow
cross-referencing Brett alright whatever
you want I'll check out his but this
guy's Carl Anderson I want the press
calls the torturer oh my Christ it looks
like serial killer X got to him painted
him up that tortured him drove him to
suicide just like I did to his victims
your lab access is terminated as of now
what boy attacks feral listen to me talk
to Rosa we're this close to getting the
guy I don't know stop it no come in to
the bureau give yourself up and we'll
talk
no okay we need to discuss yeah I'll do
it cell then play in your way but it
will find you okay fine all right
go later [ __ ] look Jake I don't like all
right well we're gonna do Karl gonna
uh-huh
slow motion King mom mr. toddler
don't you want to know what it feels
like what's going on we're not even half
done
really is he talking about having sex I
knew it he's talking about anal M yes of
course I know I was put on this earth to
bring you to justice
Wow II think the kinky stuff how they
said well her feet is you my pants oh no
does not sound well why did he gonna do
huh it's gonna change
oh my god oh my god I can see it in the
television - that's really smart
yes you've given up wait for it right
wait for it right fine would you have
put others through although it makes you
even more pathetic that you weren't
brave enough to kill yourself ever did
not read I try to do how'd you find it
and make it look right all right
whatever you want right now
No spagett you shouldn't the car here
what's going on
let my dad be a bear hug me pity have a
hidin sorry I can hug it right now all
right killing this comeback ass hey heck
back
so fast look at my stamina seriously I'm
so fast stupid okay I have two week come
on
this fight despite its super size come
on Mac come on
hey this is - hey hey hey
come on are they is Beckett
Oh always angry or you can't hit me from
here back I know you're mad packet
munites block it
that's you're not good enough on me
though I wish you could booty I did
definitely I lost my foot you know I'm
right here [ __ ]
zip it [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] ah bracket
bracket maggot that's all you have man
you suck at this
well gonna Oh ed step odd Mac the [ __ ]
is going on there's it alright
I died
very new very
very
get Leland that's not my name please
listen to me yet I am here to help
you're not yourself you are not in your
right mind
let me help you I know of what I speak
because I want his son to be gay that's
the problem
sad that what happens favorite weapon
boat haha boot power all right what's my
[ __ ] they don't know what they're
talking about
alright I think this game is coming to
an end the govern now is siting outside
side that dock
alright whatever hey you want kids
welcome to consciousness my friend what
no you won't enjoy it long yeah we were
good in the beginning what turned out to
be kind of a failure what did I do wrong
you still don't get it
uh ya know I've been using you Ethan
Thomas ah okay I don't get it you
followed you okay and used you to find
the serial killers use of desperate Oh
kill them no I I must admit yes I was a
bit dramatic yeah come on show him the
same way they'd kill their own because
there's a little gum and a bit of fun
you know I know I got it yeah she had
ruined you at the bureau but yet some
things aren't exactly that's what I was
going to say man of course since you're
no longer going to be any help what DNA
is no reason to go on this way you don't
have to cut it off how would you make it
I never happen it sorry I didn't like
the torturers methods much too risky
perhaps a slit across the throat like
the roadside konna ni da' like a short
and sweet i can then maybe the bone
cutter neatly dissected the body remove
the internal organs and label them for
the police to find that is very nice
I told me he loved you as one of mine -
oh sorry the ninja man you you see that
ninja here first right it's not a real
well find and destroy it it has caused
all this madness villain yeah cool all
right
oh I go and killing in yet I don't even
have a [ __ ] high fire how you doing
fire all right I guess boots pretty neat
fire grab fire come on grab it from
right we've been through this many times
rah it says that whoa whoa whoa climb
through it alright hey hey Harry Harry
how you doing that's the breakdancing
guys right again ready go alright cool
I'll get you in my collection tuck under
we need to find the ninja I know
flashbacks yeah come on in which way are
you talking about are you talking I
belong to what
I'm straight it's way yeah sounds ah yes
I don't have my taser sucks I'm with my
date that's convenient
all right why did he go I don't that's
not it
hi it's okay I know sticky luggage
random luggage
all right checkpoint call but where do
we have it means we're gonna fire him
here that's not good for me that all
right what the hell are you bro what
happened yeah there's something I'm
sorry on your bracelet whoa next hit
you're actually kind of good but I am
the master butch
haha you didn't have this foot power
cord to the man who did a bad Wow watch
it about that's why you voted man more
reported about what to the paper motor
the Napa port to the Napa Trevor
football ads that you get for [ __ ]
with PUD
for Justin was i tripping balls here
[ __ ]
hi it's a tractor can I ride you hello
hi Greg
he was dead he breakdowns too much cuz a
lot of times it's probably one of the
most common there yes I wish I had taser
right now I've said inhaled laughing all
right better another
ah [ __ ] me that looks disgusting
alright I would like to hear but like a
favor of you enjoyed subscribe to
corrosion and I'll see you next episode
of whatever
I'll make thousand road and I got
alright and can finally that little [ __ ]
it guns pretty good drugs left